Speaker 1: Last Friday, I covered a hearing
under oath at which radical, repugnant Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE testified. And the
point of the hearing was to ascertain whether
she incited an insurrection on January six.
The idea is if GREENE incited the insurrection,
she can't run in 2022 because you're not allowed
to incite an insurrection and then hold office.
So there was this hearing. She was under oath.
Now, she repeated that she didn't remember
just about anything. She was asked, Did you
ever suggest to Trump that he put in place
martial law? And she said, I don't remember.
Did you ever say that Nancy Pelosi should
be shot? And she said, Oh, I don't remember.
I did the on and on. And we all knew that
she was lying. We know she remembers. But
I don't recall is a legal strategy because
you're not denying that you said it, which
can be proven wrong. You're just saying you
don't remember. And the idea is. I don't remember.
I don't remember. I don't remember. They can't
prove I'm lying. This goes away. Now we know
that she committed heavy perjury. And we're
going to look at some examples. Many of you
will email me and you'll say, David, you're
not in a position to say whether it's perjury
because you don't know what was in her mind.
Perjury is state of mind. Do you know that
when you say, I don't remember, you actually
do remember. And I concede that we're not
in a courtroom here. What we are saying is,
unless she has serious dementia, it's not
plausible that she didn't remember anything
that was disadvantageous. But then when her
lawyer starts asking her the details of what
happened on January six, she says, Well, at
130 we were moved into a secure location.
And then I received a text telling us that
there had been shots fired and that, oh, now
you do remember. So we're in a court of public
opinion here on The David Pakman Show, and
it's obvious that she committed very heavy
perjury. Let's look at some examples here.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE Let's see if we can
get these up. Marjorie Taylor GREENE on January
17th texted Mark Meadows and said in our private
chat with only members. Several are saying
the only way to save our republic is for Trump
to call for martial law. By the way, instead
of martial arts ale, she spells it martial
like the name m a r s a l l, which is we're
not even going to get into that. That's funny,
too. I don't know on those things. I just
wanted you to tell him they stole this election.
We all know they will destroy our country.
Next, please tell him to declassify as much
as possible so we can go after Biden and anyone
else. So she said to Mark Meadows, I want
you to tell him martial law, communicate to
him that martial law is something that should
be considered. And then she was asked during
the hearing about this, and here's what she
said.
Speaker 2: Ms.. Green, Did you advocate President
Trump to impose martial law as a way to remain
in power?
Speaker 3: I don't recall.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So you're not denying he
did it? You just don't remember.
Speaker 3: I don't remember.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, maybe that one
she genuinely doesn't remember. Well, she
was also asked, what were you thinking when
all of the invasion started happening of the
Capitol? Who did you think was doing it? And
she said, Well, we thought it was Antifa or
Black Lives Matter.
Speaker 2: And when you were notified that
people had entered the Capitol illegally,
did you also understand that point that there
had been violence at the Capitol?
Speaker 3: I only knew what I was told. I
had heard I heard a gunshot. We all heard
it. And we were so confused. We thought Antifa
was breaking in or BLM because of those were
the riots that had gone on and on all throughout
20, 20, day in and day out.
Speaker 1: So she says in the moment they
thought that it was Antifa or Black Lives
Matter rioting at the Capitol, even though
we all knew it was the Trump people who were
at the rally, they just walked and started
writing at the Capitol. But it doesn't even
seem that she believed that because we now
have another text that she sent to Mark Meadows
as this was going on. Where she said, Mark,
I was just told there's an active shooter
on the first floor of the Capitol. Please
tell the president to calm people. This isn't
the way to solve anything. Nothing there about.
We think it's antifa. Nothing about. We think
it's Black Lives Matter. And more pointedly,
if it was Antifa or Black Lives Matter, they're
not going to listen to Trump saying, calm
down. Why would Trump calm down his enemies?
Trump would only be able to calm down the
people on his side. So another example she
obviously knew, obviously knew that the people
there were Trumpists. Last example for today,
although there was many more during Marjorie
Taylor Greene's Under Oath hearings, she was
asked about a Capitol rioter named Anthony
Agoro and. In the testimony, she said he's
a distant friend. I've not spent much time
with him. He's just a distant friend. Although
Agoro referred to Marjorie Taylor GREENE as
a great friend, as a close friend. Well, there
is now deleted video. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
has deleted this video where she said he is
a great friend of hers. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Because my friend Anthony is my
dear, dear friend.
Speaker 1: My dear, dear friend Anthony. Not
a distant friend. No, no, no. My dear, dear
friend.
Speaker 3: I love him so much. He's one of
the greatest guys I know.
Speaker 1: One of the greatest guys I know.
I love him so much. So just another example
of the obvious perjury. When Marjorie Taylor
GREENE said, I don't remember. I don't recall.
Not really, my friend. I don't really know.
Now I'm right there with you. To be prosecuted
for perjury is very difficult. You have to
prove she knew she was lying. You have to
prove she did. Remember. So it's strategic
memory loss. And by every legal analysis I've
seen, it's an effective strategy. But she
obviously lied. We'll have these clips on
our Instagram at David
Pakman show.